this man knows the answers
the pm's former advisor arriving in
parliament to give his account
of this government's covert crisis and
from the outset
not holding back the truth is that
senior ministers senior officials
senior advisers like me fell
disastrously short of the standards that
the public has a right to expect
of its government in a crisis like this
when the public needed us most the
government failed
and i'd like to say to all the families
of those who uh who died unnecessarily
how sorry i am for the mistakes that
were made and for my own mistakes of
that
early last year as china began to lock
down
kovid wasn't part of our daily lives but
it was coming
and the government was not alive to the
threat the government itself
and number 10 was not
operating on a war footing in february
on this in any way shape or form
lots of key people were literally skiing
the pm wasn't skiing but he was on
holiday too
in evening in kent whilst there he
missed a number of
emergency cobra meetings in mr cummings
view
that may have been a good thing in
february the prime minister
regarded this as just a scare story
he regarded he describes it as the new
swine flu did you tell him it wasn't
certainly but the view of various
officials inside number 10 was
if we have the prime minister chair in
cobra meetings and he just tells
everyone
it's swine flu don't worry about it i'm
going to get chris whitty to inject me
live on tv with coronavirus so everyone
realizes
it's nothing to be frightened of that
would be
that would not help actually serious
planning it has this graph here
mr cummings says the initial plan was to
try to reach hard immunity in the
population before the autumn of 2020
to avoid a huge winter spike a plan
denied by the government
either community by september or has
heard immunity by january after
after a second peak that that was the
that was the assumption
so when matt hancock said on the 15th of
march
we have a plan herd immunity is not part
of it
was that wrong that was the plan
i don't i'm completely baffled as to why
number 10 has tried to deny that
but it soon became clear the hard
immunity plan would lead to hundreds of
thousands of deaths
and on march the 13th mr cummings and
senior officials
met in number 10 and drew up plan b we
basically say we're going to sit down
with prime minister tomorrow and explain
to him
that we think that we're going to have
to ditch the whole official plan and
we're heading for
the biggest disaster this currently seen
since 1940. at this point
the second most powerful official in the
country helen mcnamara is the deputy
cabinet secretary
she walked into the office while we're
looking at this whiteboard
she says i've just been talking to the
official mark sweeney
who is in charge of coordinating with
the department for health
he said quote i've been told for years
that there is a whole plan for this
there is no plan we're in huge trouble
i've come through here to the telemachum
said i've come through here to the prime
minister's office to tell you all
quote i think we are absolutely
i think this country's heading for
disaster i think we're going to kill
thousands of people
plan b meant lockdown on the 14th we
said to the prime minister
you are going to have to lock down but
there is no lockdown plan
it doesn't exist this is like a scene
from independence day with jeff goldblum
saying the aliens are here and your
whole plan is broken and you need a new
plan right
that is what the scene was like that
morning a picture of total chaos in
government
but mr cummings singling out one
individual in particular
i think that the secretary of state for
health should have been fired
for at least 15 20 things including
lying to everybody
in multiple occasions in meeting after
meeting in the
in the cabinet room and publicly i think
i heard you correctly in accusing the
health secretary of having lied
did i hear that correctly yes can you
that's obviously a serious charge can
you provide the committee with
the the evidence behind that assertion
yes in the summer he said that everyone
who needed treatment
who got the treatment that they required
he knew that that was a lie
and in april last year the health
secretary announced a hundred thousand
a day testing target in my opinion he
should have been fired for that
thing alone and that itself meant that
the whole of april was hugely disrupted
by um you know different parts of
whitehall fundamentally trying to
operate in different ways
completely because hancock wanted to be
able to go on tv and say
look at me my 100k target it was
criminal
disgraceful behavior that caused serious
harm we had this terrible pledge which
was hugely
distorting the whole system we also had
constant repeated lying about ppe
the cabinet secretary said to the prime
minister in almost the first meeting
when he came back
prime minister the british system is not
set
up to deal with the secretary of state
who repeatedly lies in meetings
brexit brought mr cummings and boris
johnson together and brexit brought them
to number 10
but beyond brexit mr cummings not sure
they were the right men for the job
it's completely crackers that someone
like me should have been in there just
the same as this crack as the boris
johnson
was in there and that the choice of the
last election was jeremy corbyn the
problem in this crisis was
very much lines led by donkeys over and
over again
the leadership people like me and the
prime minister
and the secretary of state for health we
let down the people on the front line
after the misery of lockdown the brief
respite of summer
it was then mr cummings told the pm he'd
had enough
and would resign at the end of the year
i'm not prepared to
um to work with people like hancock
anymore i've told you um teen times
you've got to remove him
you won't it's going to be a disaster in
the autumn and therefore it's time that
i should go and the prime minister said
which i think
says a lot he said he laughed and he
said you're right i am more frightened
of you having the power to stop the
chaos that i am with the chaos chaos
isn't that bad chaos means that everyone
has to look to me
to see who's in charge but with chaos
came terrible policy failures
the decision to discharge caved positive
patients back into care homes
cost the lives of so many do you have
any insight into how that
decision uh was taken
hancock told us in the cabinet room that
people were going to be tested before
they went back to care homes
what the hell happened now or the
government rhetoric was we put a shield
around care homes and blah blah
it was complete nonsense quite the
opposite of putting a shield around them
we sent people with covert back to the
care homes
that's extraordinary another misstep mr
cummings own apparent breach of lockdown
rules moving his family from london to
durham he now claims for security
reasons
that whole episode was um definitely
a major disaster for the government and
for
and for the covert policy a central
figure but certainly not
the one in charge if i could have
clicked my fingers
and done things there would have been a
serious border policy
masks would have been compulsory hancock
would have been fired we'd have done you
know like
dozens and dozens and dozens of things
what happened is
like fundamentally the prime minister
and i did not agree about covet
and there was a fundamental disagreement
over the second lockdown
mr cummings and the scientists wanted it
mr johnson did not
surely you've got to learn the lessons
from the past and
our prime minister decided no and said
basically
just get a hit and hope but there was a
second lockdown and it was the beginning
of the end for mr cummings's time
in number 10. and in his view he's not
the only one who shouldn't be working
behind the black door
by the 31st of october our relations
were essentially already
finished the fact that his girlfriend
also wanted rid of me was you know
relevant but not the heart of the heart
of the problem
the other problem was uh fundamentally i
regarded him as unfit for the job
the pm's conduct in office in question
did you hear them say
let the bodies pile high in their
thousands or it's only killing
eighty-year-olds
i heard that in prime minister study
that's something the pm
has explicitly denied saying at least
one of them
is lying the parliamentary committee
hearing is not the major inquiry into
the handling of this pandemic
that starts next year too late says mr
cummings
i think the idea that any kind of
serious inquiry in lessons learned
doesn't start till next year
is is completely terrible
the families of all tens of thousands of
people died who didn't need to die
there is absolutely no excuse for
delaying that
prime minister's questions is normally
the main event in westminster
not today opposition parties worried by
what they've heard
there's a pattern of behaviour here
there was clearly a lack of planning
poor decision making and a lack of
transparency and a prime minister who
was absent from the key decisions
the prime minister defending his record
i am truly sorry for the suffering that
the people of this country uh have
experienced but i
maintain my point that the government
acted throughout
uh with the intention to save life and
protect the
nhs and in accordance with the best
scientific advice that's exactly what we
do
over seven hours of questioning for mr
cummings
now people will look to his former
colleagues for answers
the time will come for the pm to tell
his own story
but for now mr cummings account is the
first draft of history
beth rigby sky news